Будівництво вже ведеться, а в генплані Києва його немає.
Тут, на лівому березі Дніпра,навколо трьох найбільших озер міста
впродовж останніх 5 років руйнується екосистема заливних лук
задля зведення кількох житлових багатоповерхівок.
Місцеві мешканці постійно протестують проти будівництва,
намагаються заблокувати рух бетоновозів.
Навіть створили окрему громадську організацію,
аби юридично зупинити будівництво і реалізувати
свій проект - "Екопарк Осокорки".
Один зактивістів Максим Стравінський розповідає,
що організація зібрала докази про низку корупційних порушень
щодо дозволів на забудову цієї території, починаючи з2005року.
Ці дані передали в правоохоронні органи.
Але поки жоден з посадовців не був покараний.
І ні місцеві, ні центральні органи влади, в тому числі
адміністрація президента, доякої теж зверталися активісти,
нічого не зробили для скасування дозволу на будівництво.
Єдине, чого поки вдалося досягти - це рішення Київміськради
про оголошення лише третини цієї території
природним заповідним парком.
Є дуже парадоксальна ситуація в тому, що
законодавча база дозволяє відстоювати екологічні
питання громади й країни в цілому.
Але саме невиконання цих законів
і недотримання контролю з боку відповідних органів
дає можливість обходити ці закони і робити ці втручання.
Громадські активісти сподіваються, що з приходом до влади
"несистемного" Володимира Зеленського ситуація з тотальною,
на їхній погляд, корупцією в галузі будівництва
та охорони природи може змінитися.
Активісти закликають команду Зеленського
оголосити збереження довкілля стратегічним
напрямком розвитку країни.
Адже "гарячих точок" знищення зелених зон в Україні багато.
Нова команда може ініціювати створення відповідних органів
чи окремого якогосьомбудсмена,
який би опікувавсясаме екологічними питаннями.
Якби була політична воля, то підконтрольні президенту генпрокуратура і СБУ
рішучіше реагували б на корупцію, кажуть у "TI".
Антикорупціонери розповідають, як багато зусиль громадські організації,
міжнародні партнери України доклали, аби
впровадити новий закон про тендерні закупівлі,
де обов’язковим пунктом є проведення торгів через систему "Прозоро".
Завдяки "Прозоро" держава тепер щомісяця
заощаджує мінімум мільярд гривень.
Проте вже фіксують випадки, коли в регіонах
знаходять лазівки, як проводити закупівлі без "Прозоро".
Коли є порушення закону, далі мають реагувати правоохоронні органи,
Державна аудиторська служба.
На жаль, в цьому плані в нас є куди рости.
І, наприклад, одним з пріоритетів, який мав би бути в найближчі роки -
це реформа Державної аудиторської служби, яка є
основним контролюючим органом у цій галузі.
Активісти-антикорупціонери в галузі медицини дуже сподіваються,
що зміна голови держави не призведе до зупинки
чи втрати досягнень однієї з наймасштабніших в Україні реформ - медичної.
Що закупівля ліків для важкохворих  і далі проводитиметься
через міжнародні організації, а не стане джерелом наживи фармацевтів.
Що до лікарень будуть потрапляти не 40 відсотків ліків,
як раніше, а усі сто, а через відкриту для усіх систему "Єліки"
можна буде відстежити їхню наявність у тій чи іншій лікарні.
І головне - щоб Україна, як і планується, в2020році
взялася б до реалізації другого етапу реформи - вторинної медицини.
50-т пацієнтських організацій вже звернулися до Зеленського
з проханням зберегти команду медичних реформаторів.
Це не лише топ-менеджмент міністерства охорони здоров’я.
За цей час було створено кілька дуже потужних інституцій.
Це сотні людей, які в цьому задіяні.
Ми дуже сподіваємося, що ця команда буде збережена і посилена.
У "TI" вважають, що період політичної турбулентності,
пов'язаний з передачею влади, затягнеться мінімум на півроку.
І тільки після цього справа може дійти до антикорупційної галузі: .
налагодження повноцінної роботи Антикорупційного суду,
можливо, зміна керівника САП, повернення до
Кримінального кодексу статі про незаконне збагачення чиновників.
Цього активісти вимагали від ще чинного
президента Порошенка, вимагатимуть і від нового.
А також завершення розслідування та покарання виконавців
і замовників майже 50-ти нападів на активістів
по всій країні за останні кілька років.
Активісти сподіваються, що нова влада покаже,
що їй не байдуже те, що відбувається в громадському секторі.